لذلك أريد فقط أن أؤكد هنا
لأنه من المهم أنه قبل هذه
الاستقالة ، هل هذه الحكومة تستقيل
لأنه إذا كان من المفترض أنك
فقدت وظيفتك ، نعم بالطبع ،
فإن جميع الوزراء سيقومون الآن
بواجب تصريف الأعمال حتى
يتم تشكيل الحكومة الجديدة  قلت إن رئيس الوزراء
قدم استقالته خطياً رسمياً
وسيكون الأمر
متروكاً لرئيس الجمهورية لإعلان القبول ،
كما أنه سيدعو جميع
الوزراء لمواصلة القيام
بمهام تصريف الأعمال الخاصة بهم حتى يتم تشكيل حكومة جديدة
الحكومة السابقة أو الحكومة السابقة.
الحكومة التي قد تنتظر المفتاح الذي
كان يجب أن تحذر من القبول في
يناير ، اسمحوا لي أن أشرح نعم ، لكن كما
قلت وفقًا للدستور ، فإن
هذه الاستقالة فعالة ولكن
هناك أيضًا خطوة ثانية
يتعين على الرئيس القيام بها للحكومة الحالية
أنا في
سلفي كنت أقوم برعاية لمدة
تسعة أشهر لذلك آمل ألا يكون هذا هو
الوضع الآن وأنا  نتمنى
أن نتحرك في عملية أسرع
لأنه كما تعلم ، قام رئيس الوزراء
بذلك بشكل غير متوقع أو بدون
التنسيق مع الكتل المختلفة
التي تشكل الأغلبية التي
ستسمي رئيس وزراء جديدًا
وفقًا للدستور ، ما فعله رئيس الوزراء
اليوم وفقًا للدستور.  إلى
الدستور تم احترام الدستور في لبنان
، وجاء ذلك
بعد أن ذكرت مظاهرة طويلة
في الشوارع حيث
يحق للناس الاحتجاج والتحدث والتحدث
عن آرائهم
[موسيقى]